so let's let's start with first uh the
John Wick 4 trailer uh it looks kind of
good I think I'm gonna see the movie
I've decided I'm gonna go
that's good I'm glad we're already
trying to push push that audience into
the theater exactly
um you have a release date of March I'm
sure everyone is wondering where are you
in the editing process
uh as we sit I'm about to go to my next
di session we're pretty close where the
picture is pretty much locked we're just
getting in our VFX and doing our
coloring and we're starting our sound
mix in a week or two so we're in the
final Death Rows is it going to be the
longest of all the movies
it has the longest run time of all the
movies hopefully it won't feel the
longest
uh for listen I If You released a four
hour version of this movie I'd be the
first one in theaters but most people
can't take that is there a little bit
like how do you how do you guys or how
do you debate as a director
um because there's a lot of people that
love a two-hour movie but I'm I'm fine
with a two and a half or a three hour as
long as it justifies its running time so
can you sort of talk about was there a
big debate in terms of how long this
movie was going to be oh yeah I mean
yeah I get it you know it's where
Commerce meets art right it's always
going to be that and you'll hear the
excuses about more more trailers more
showings more stuff like that like I I
get I don't agree with that argument but
I get it I think the
the main thing is like look I'm from a
different generation I'm with you as
long I could watch Butch Cassidy and
Sundance Kid all day long watch Lawrence
of Arabia in one sitting I can literally
watch and I have watched in less than a
weekend in the entire Peter Jackson
Extended Cut of Lord of the Rings on all
three films and I'm good and I soak it
up
um yeah there's slow spots and there's
all that kind of stuff I get that look I
we know there's a certain kind of pace
and correction movies we get that
there's a certain kind of appetite for
and we have luckily we have a little bit
of margin because we have a little bit
of World building with the action in
John Wick look I I've watched this thing
now this version of the cut
close to 100 times and I'll another 100
by the end of the month at least and
this is the first one that we watch and
we kind of I I
don't get bored at all like it's my own
film I know it's weird to say but like I
watch it I was like oh I pre like I'm
still in the movie it doesn't take me
out I don't ever feel like [ __ ] just end
this thing already I can't watch it
again you know I mean other than other
than my other misgivings of choices and
and scenes and writing all that stuff I
I feel pretty good about it and when
kale and I and the the really tight
Circle that I have around us
we've watched like every week we have a
little group let's just watch it one
more time to make sure we're not talking
ourselves into something and as long as
that gut feeling feels good
like what else do you go with right like
I can't go off somebody else's gut
feeling and I've had people who I who I
trust and know say well it's too long
cut 20 minutes out and you're like okay
that's your feeling it's your opinion
if I go with anybody else's opinion
other than mine which I haven't done in
any other decision in the movie where's
that gonna go I mean we wrote a longer
movie we wrote a bigger movie we wrote a
longer script we wrote you know at least
a third more scenes than the last one
like we expect it to be more we've
always expected it to be more and I
think
the test or at least what we're judging
ourselves by is that worth it with how
we executed what we wanted to be more
and I think the answer is yes like so if
I if I watched it and I have a pretty
good endurance like you but if I watched
it I went
yeah no I don't I start looking at my
watch I I know it's time to cut but I
don't look at my watch in this so I'm
gonna I feel pretty good Where It's At
Last Question on the run time uh do you
want to tell me how long it is
uh still not entirely determined I'd
hate to give you a number because I
haven't given the studio the overall
number yet so I want to give them the
number first sure is it can I ask you is
it a is it close to two and a half hours
or it's in that zone it's in that zone I
I think you know it's I I I'm Different
like you know the the you know
definition of runtime is that first logo
to that last credit you know what I mean
so the movie itself I know what it runs
at I I don't know the full runtime
because I don't know the credit scroll
and all the other stuff that's going in
so you'd have to add on that but it it's
in the zone of
yeah it's it's it's it's in that you
know it's it's over the two-hour Mark
but it's under a lot of the other big
marks so I I understand I'm just gonna
when I do a story I'm just gonna say
it's around two and a half hours because
it sounds like that's probably what it
is yeah we're somewhere in there so um
right now the trailer says it's called
John Wick chapter four are you is that
the final title or are you gonna add a
word
it's a work in progress right now we're
trying to find the right theme and
hopefully it'll work out the way we
thought and I don't want to give it away
but
um
yeah that's a working title we still
have the proper title to come out in the
trailer and I'm just I'm going to ask
you some questions about the trailer is
that John Wick's mom in the trailer
smile which one's John Wick's mom well
I'm just out I'm just asking there's a
woman uh which near the fight like with
the boxes that's on fire with the glowy
thing and it's um because he uh Winston
says something about your family you
know oh oh no Natalie no no no no no no
uh no no no the uh no
uh I mean by the way I'm just I'm just
I'm just I'm just taking stabs here I
would say uh kind of like in the film
Arizona kind of like a stepsister I
wouldn't call her stepson but like in
the zone of that yeah
it's his former family I guess in the
trailer there is a huge action set piece
that looks like around the Arc de
Triumph and I'm just curious what the
hell is it like filming a huge action
set piece in one of the most popular
tourist destinations in Europe
I would say the greatest word would be
tricky very tricky uh you know obviously
we do what we can where we're at and
then we try to the movie Magic our way
through some of the trickier stuff but
yeah it's you know we had an amazing
location
Diversity on the Scout from soccer Kurt
the Arctic triumphs to the Louvre to you
know the Eiffel Tower to some amazing
places throughout I mean we were you
know we're in Aqaba Jordan for of our
opening sequence
Paris Berlin Tokyo Osaka you know we
kind of got around on this one so
hopefully we brought all that great
imagery to screen did you actually get
to film in the Louvre
we actually shot in the loop yes is
there action in The Louvre
I didn't push it quite that far let's
just say we shot a really cool sandal
here they got a little weird you start
you start shooting and blowing [ __ ] up
next to a Caravaggio they get a little
edgy but no they were wonderful they let
us come into a great scene there yeah
I'm assuming it's it's a dialogue scene
because I don't think they want you
touching or risking anything yeah no
that's I would agree with that yeah
there was I mean that's the first thing
they asked you and they kind of laughed
like you're not gonna shoot anything
right I was like I don't know can I run
there I was like just kidding just
kidding we just want to shoot right
um who does Bill Skarsgard actually play
in the film his character's name is uh
just his broad name is the Marquee the
Marquee is like uh without giving too
much away I I wouldn't really say the
antagonist but he's the one in charge of
cleaning up all the messes from the
first three movies right it does seem
like in the trailer uh it makes it seem
like there's a little bit of a a reboot
of the pecking order yeah completely
rebooted to the Pokemon he's being
brought into to to reset the reset the
calendar
uh there's a scene I want to make sure I
got this right there's a scene where
Bill uh Donnie Keanu and Lawrence are
sitting around a table near the Eiffel
Tower
um and Bill is saying the cable will
honor its word
um I know that location assuming that
there's no green screen there like
that's a really that's the Eiffel Tower
yeah that that's where for people that
don't realize that that's where they did
the mission impossible red carpet right
around there
um so what was it like filming there and
having these great actors with the
Eiffel Tower in the background it's
always good I don't tell my cast too
much I kind of give them the setting we
have a little chat but there's nothing
like you know it's 5 a.m we're just
setting up the lights it's still dark
out they get out of the car we're gonna
do our read through and then you know
they get out of the SUV and it's you
know the [ __ ] Eiffel Tower right
there in this great table and okay guys
let's warm it up it kind of you you do
all these read-throughs in the in these
Studio rooms beforehand and you kind of
do your little acting rehearsals but
when you really see it that was like my
Barry Lyndon set where you know I don't
know if you remember very linen but like
big fan of of the cabrikian way he did
that so we placed everybody in this
really really Renaissance kind of way
and like this is when you explain that
in a room in an office it's one thing
but when you see it with the Eiffel
Tower the Symmetry they all started to
get the the the uh the the Symmetry and
the artistic nature of what we're trying
to do when they get there and there's
nothing like seeing their faces when
they go oh I get what you're saying now
it's pretty cool you have uh dogs in the
trailer uh and dogs have played a big
part of the John Wick movies
um and you know with with Halle Berry
there was a lot of dog stuff how is it
in this movie is it on that same level
or is it just sort of it's a part of the
movie it's a part of the movie it's
slightly different but when the dog does
his does sorry does her thing uh it's a
cool thing
it's a cool thing so it's really it's a
it's a different character that has a
different type of dog and how they use
him is a little differently so Holly
spent a lot of time with the dogs and
training and you taught the dogs that
this is a movie and you can play how
long did you work with her the new dog
uh to uh get ready well the character of
the dog is a her but we had let's see
three females and two male dogs to come
all one dog together depending on what
the the stunt or the gag or the acting
bit was
um this time we learned a lot from last
time but we wanted a little bit more out
of this one in specialty stuff we had
the dogs I think it was just over five
months
to work with capital stunts it's just
when you're bringing in the stunt teams
and you know we have different stunt
teams on this one because it's so much
bigger the dog has to you know get to
it's just like friends you have to get
to know your friends so for north of the
dog to be very playful and safe and have
the confidence just like a human would
they have to spend time with each
individual stunt guy so we had to rotate
every hour you know one of our 10 main
stunt Team guys would go and play that
was his job he had to go play with the
dogs and get tackled by the dogs and
play Frisbee with the dog so you get
acclimated to the to the
to our canine friend and then that's how
we started working it but it was about a
little over five months yeah I'm always
wondering if uh if if the dogs ever go
home with any of the stunt performers
you know to really Bond yeah no they go
home with the trainers like every
trainer is in charge of like one animal
that goes home and they live with them
and go but the stunt guy spent a lot if
they're not in the stunt rehearsal Hall
with piano or cast or choreographing
they're with the dogs they don't take
them home but they spend a lot of I mean
a lot of time with the animals yeah
Clancy Brown makes an appearance in the
trailer
listen I love Clancy and obviously
that's a little nod to uh anytime I see
Clancy I just see a Highlander
so how does he have just a small role
who does he play he has a pivotal role
he plays a character called the
harbinger
who is everything that word stands for
I understand uh he gives the whole
sentiment and he's like our our high
table referee
oh that's yeah because he's giving out
the guns yeah I get it he's uh our
officiate
uh same question about Shamir
Shamir is a whole different kind of
character
um his character's name is the tracker
again name says it all and everyone's
got everybody's got a purpose
everybody's got a reason everybody's got
a motivation his is uh at least
initially self-motivated he becomes a
character that's kind of in the gray
area between the two worlds the wick
world and the real world who does uh
Hiro yuku play hiroyuki Sonata what I've
known hiroyuki forever been a fan of his
forever like like 30-year fan and
finally getting to work with him because
you know he works with Dave a lot Dave's
always been able to get him for like on
whether it's Wolverine or bullet train
or anything like that and I had him on
he's really gonna play a part for me in
John Wick 3 but he tore his Achilles
Tenon right before he came
so that's how the whole market cost this
thing came out hiroyuki had a bail the
surgery so then we went to a friend Mark
de Costas on this it was like literally
as soon as I knew what I was going to
write I was like don't take another gig
make sure you tell me you're in John
week four I gotta now you're just gonna
write the part so like he was cool
um he plays an old friend of John Wicks
if I'm not mistaken in the trailer
there's footage of him fighting Donnie
he has a moment we've done again yes he
does I mean when you have hiroyuki
Sonata Donnie Yen going at it it's
always fun and they're
when you have guys that come from the
action genre world and like they both
love to act they both it's funny they
all have that similar thread they just
don't want to try they don't want to be
trophy they want to try something new
they're very brave
you know it's not like falling back into
the same let's just do the style I'm
good at let's because you have Hiroki
that's used to the Japanese way of doing
things very precise and you have Donnie
it's really you know the epitome of Hong
Kong action of let's just be great and
make it up on the day and get the energy
so to put them together and to find a
little organic mix was really fun and
they had a good time I think the respect
was there and
super courteous to each other and
literally just you know we had all our
grand ideas of choreography and stuff
and then it comes down to two guys just
doing it really well and you watching me
like uh yeah okay I'm gonna shut up now
let you guys do anything when they were
fighting on uh in the film did you
notice that an awful lot of people
needed to be on set that day yeah like
there was no shortages done people on
the sidelines like everybody came out to
watch yeah they're just they're great
humans incredibly creative and super
talented so like yeah of course there's
a natural prisoner that you just want to
watch these guys do their thing and the
funny thing is these guys couldn't be
happier doing their thing there's no
weird there's no insecurity there's no
war people like they just they're
actually having Yale cut it's supposed
to be a serious name but you know cut
and they're like you know these great
high-five at each other and I watch it
here you can donate Donnie Yen high five
each other go good job thank you what
can I do for like just like great stuff
guys like what can how can I make you
look better like still giving so giving
talk a little bit about with the trailer
how much did you debate how much to show
and like can you sort of talk about that
line because obviously you want to hold
stuff back but you also need to get
people in the theater look uh brutally
honest like I you know I don't know a
single director including myself that
would want to do more than a 10 second
trailer foreign
if it was up to me I wouldn't show
anything I'd give you 15 seconds and
make it all a mystery because that's
what I did and I get into the argument
with with marketing all the time and
look I I've learned my lesson on that
like you and I are hardcore genre guys
and we get like we like the knit like
you know but to get the movie out there
to get the fans
look I'm always the same I'm like what
the [ __ ] are you doing like there's too
much you got to cut it down
and they're like you know we get it we
get it you got to protect and your your
baby and stuff and then they go through
the rationale behind it you're like all
right maybe I should just shut up and
let you guys so I'm
I'm fairly resistant right off the bat
I'm like oh my God there's the same I
was like oh my God
show me 15 seconds
and then you gotta listen after I blow
my fuse yell and go freak out and bang
my head and scream and threaten and then
they go okay crazy director guy let's
talk
like all right that's pretty smart I
think being being a director that knows
how to Market something is being a good
director that knows how to shut up and
let the pros do their thing and they
invite me in for the creative which is
cool about what look if there's a better
shot if there's a better way that you
try to help with that but I try not to
delve too much into the marketing plan
I've been proven wrong before and again
if it was my way you wouldn't see any
other movie until we got there so I'm
gonna go with what I learned in the last
couple years of trust trust your
marketing team and try to support them
as best you can and help them out
creatively and logistically as much as
you can and hopefully that'll be a good
campaign so yeah I've always I've
wondered uh and I've mentioned this to
marketing people but like you know with
the internet and everyone always looking
for Content all the time I mean was
there ever any thought of like you and
Keanu just sort of sitting around and
like looking at the camera be like hey
I'm Chad hey I'm Keanu we have a new
John Wick movie coming out in March and
you know it's going to be pretty good
blah blah blah like you know some
[ __ ] kind of a thing that you know
and then at the end you're doing like 10
seconds of footage right I think you
know what that's a that's a great idea
on the next one for sure
um I think just a personality thing like
look we all know movies that do market
like that and you know it also comes
that personality like look like that's a
Ryan Reynolds thing like Elijah like
Ryan's got that person out like he's
he's out in it and that that works for
him he's got the the the the the
personality to pull that off I
personally am not that guy
um I just want to sit there like I love
ripping with you about like I could go
down every toy and backy right there and
have a story with you I'm good with that
and if you want to have a glass of
scotch over it we're good I'll try to
stay out of the lens as much as possible
and I you you've met Keon and stuff like
that he's a reserved guy that wants to
nerd out with you too in the back room
uh and plus I you know I think Kim and I
are both the same we we want you guys to
experience John Wick we want you to have
it you don't need us to talk about it go
see it for the character go see it for
the guy you know if anything we'll give
you the cool hey this is Chad this is
Keanu thank you it's more of a thank you
like thank you so much for liking the
crazy stuff we put on screen best of
luck take it for what you will and have
fun you know
um you are collaborating again with Dan
on the cinematography I really I really
love Dan's work
um can you talk about the aesthetic that
you guys were going for with this taking
place around the world and not really in
New York City the way the previous films
have been I mean you know maybe are you
trying to use different colors or you
know what I mean to try to differentiate
this one really look um the whole Milli
or the whole vibe on this automatic was
okay let's try to be an art film we're
gonna blowship I'm gonna try and be very
artsy we're going to take all this
Modern Art lighting stuff whether it's
like um Olaf Eliason or Tyrell or any of
these great modern artists that use
light let's try to imitate and try to
use that in every set piece so we up our
lighting game and we let you know that
it's
you know again neon Noir is probably one
of the best descriptive terms I've heard
of our franchise and that's what we
wanted to do combine that with thematic
set pieces that happen in Japan so you
have your cherry blossoms your Reds your
pinks your purples your softer colors
that you don't get in action movies a
lot combined it with the greens and the
grit of like Berlin at its like techno
best and then you can go with the shine
and the glitz of Paris and then you can
tie that all together with the rich
magic Hour Gold of the desert of the
Sahara Desert the Jordanian desert I
mean that's kind of where we went we're
gonna go okay we're gonna go big artsy
lighting film and we're going to take
cues from the locations we're in like
what's what's your best anime version of
Osaka what's your anime version of
Berlin and what's your anime version of
of uh either New York or uh Jordan in
the previous films there's always been
one set piece that really was the pain
in the ass the one that you [ __ ]
hated
um which set piece is it in this one and
uh how did you solve it well
I love them all Steve I love them all so
much harder to bring up um I would say
there's three that were always like
you've already mentioned they are to try
I'm trying to pull that off and do what
we did in it with a hundred drivers were
was interesting
um
you know also interesting I guess
um we have a a club sequence that we did
in Berlin which in deals which uh you
see in the trailer it uses a lot of
water features so if you don't mind
being under about a million gallons of
water every night
with 300 dancers and stuff like that
that's a it's a Cool vibe but it can
wear on you a little bit
um and then we have a sequence that's
not in any of the trailers so I don't
give any away but that was the trickiest
logistically and mathematically hard to
figure out about how to pull everything
off as we did and I think that's the one
that'll kind of Pop the most in the
movie so we'll talk about that again
soon I'm sure uh 100 I know I'm just
about out of time with you so I'm just
going to ask
um you've been linked to a whole bunch
of projects uh in terms of what you're
going to direct and I am curious are you
does what what is actually going to
happen after WIC four are you actually
gonna make a different thing do you know
what that's going to be or is it too
early to figure out uh it's not too
early
um but I haven't quite figured out look
I the projects I'm attached to I do love
our latest version of Highlander I do
love the script I currently have for
goes to sushima there's just a couple
other things that are filling out
between cast and Logistics with the
studio about where how when and who's
gonna you know how the thing actually
comes out we're at that weird spot in
the industry now between streaming and
features and Theatrical and what is and
what isn't and where Studios want to put
their money and I think
uh you know I'm tied to a lot of genre
stuff like like Wick it's a weird thing
Highlands are weird I have a weird take
on it it goes to Shima you know all
Japanese cast period piece in the
Kurosawa kind of anime aesthetic and
they're just trying to figure out where
where we best or where I can reach the
biggest audience where can we do the
most work where can we get the best
budget for it
and go so like creatively I would love
to do nine out of ten like you you read
about Black Samurai which is an
incredible series of books from the 70s
that we've had a [ __ ] fantastic take
on that I'd really love to jump into too
it's just
unfortunately they're all big
specialistic kind of genre projects that
take a lot of prep so we're kind of in a
little race who can get there literally
who can get their [ __ ] together
first and then that's the one I'll
probably go with that so that's the
thing that so many people don't realize
is that like you're attached to all
these different projects but it's about
what script is the best one that has
come up what has the actors a scheduling
availability what you know it's these
weird things that people don't realize
that really control your decisions if
you rush in any one thing you you can
get I don't think most people realize
how how bad people always ask well you
know I get asked why there's so many bad
movies and like if you knew the working
parts the real question is how are there
so many good movies because like it's
it's astounding to realize how fast so
much money and so many parts can go to
[ __ ] it really can like just because
you're a little too anxious so you miss
a step or you don't get the right
Finance the next you know that actor
falls out and this location falls out so
next thing you're doing is Sound Stage
in Budapest for you know a Bahama movie
you know and it it literally goes to
[ __ ] that quick over you know group
think thinking oh yeah we'll get through
that one problem well it's not one
problem the Ripple effects is a thousand
problems so you try to get as many
[ __ ] positive things like you get
your cash you get your crew you get your
location you get your budget you get
your schedule you got that much you can
make a movie you miss any one of those
things you have problems that's the
trick always the other thing though is
that you know Lionsgate being blunt is
you know the John Wick uh the John Wick
universe is now expanding with ballerina
with the Continental with the whole John
Wick movies and I don't even know what
else they're thinking about but I mean
I'm I'm assuming also they're gonna say
to you right after you finish four so
when do you guys want to make five you
know um they did that a couple weeks ago
Steve it's all good well by the way I'm
sure they are because it's a it's a I
mean this is a you know it's a very very
popular franchise you know we're lucky
to have them I mean you know Nathan
cahane and Joe Drake and all the guys
over there they're super positive they
love it they love seeing
the smile on our face we go they're
super supportive you know they get it
and if it was them I'm sure as long as
Keanu want to do it I'm sure they'd find
a way to make it happen so that's always
something you know that you just makes
you feel fortunate makes you feel lucky
so that's good oh no completely there's
I mean the fact of the matter that if
anyway yes everyone who gets to work in
Hollywood is very lucky
um so so basically you really don't know
after you wrap on for what you're going
to do next I have my hopes I have my
hope Steve let's see what let's see if
they come true